if you want to get to $100 million a
year for example well you're not going
to die and then be reborn and then live
the next 20 years as a CFO in order to
know how to run the finances of that
company and you're not going to die and
then be reborn and then do 10 years of
product so that you know how to build
something that's sticky and that people
want to keep buying and renew on most of
the times the founder has a strength or
two that has gotten them to this point
and then there's huge deficiencies in
the business and so one of the big
misnomers about growing a business is
that people say double down in your
strengths which is absolutely true for
the individual but the business needs to
be balanced and so that's the push and
pool that people Miss in context is that
even though you may be really good at
sales and marketing for example your
business in order to get to the next
level still needs to have an exceptional
product still needs to have a financial
function an HR function an IT function
so you can track data Etc